пані підласи категорично не хочу чути
яка є реальність із дронами і говорилося
що я тут якусь неправду говорю про 40
млрдв використання так от я маю лист від
держспецзв'язку від
27.09 якому чітко розписано скільки І що
на 40 млрд зроблено не не вдаючись в
деталі наголошу що на трошки більше ніж
на половину суми укладено контракти а
нарешту планується укласти контракти
поставок майже немає тому ця правка
передбачає що 1, млрд які хочуть
виділити Фонду розвитку інновацій
ефмерному зараз треба забирати І
передавати безпосередньо на збройні сили
України щоби була пряма закупівля Дронів
не через держспецзв'язок а через
агентство закупівель яке при
міністерстві оборони яке відповідає
стандартам НАТО і я прошу вивчати
реальну ситуацію скористайтеся
запрошенням моїх коліжан от поїхати на
фронт взнати що є як